he's Peter Schrager co-host of NFL
Network's good morning football
foxsports.com senior national writer and
he's gonna be busy during the draft you
can also catch Peter with Jay Glazer and
Joel Klat know there's some heavy
hitters throughout the entire first
round on Thursday live on Fox Sports
Radio breaking down the draft pick by
pick beginning at 8:00 Eastern Thursday
on Fox Sports Radio Peter how are you
I'm doing well all things considered
there we got the little fella ought to
talk about and oh no the light here
there's a light at the end of the tunnel
and I think it's a light in the short
term you got something to talk about
sports while I'm here to do it all right
the draft begins where track begins at
number three because our boroughs going
one to Cincinnati chase Young at two I'm
told is 99% Redskins I don't think
they're going to train it unless I get
some ridiculous offer then you got the
Lions at three and it gets a little
interesting here I think you add in the
fact that there's going to be some
technical glitches so all these teams
are still trying to figure this thing
out and then the Lions would be willing
to listen to offers but I think it's
been overblown that there's suddenly
some some great desire to move up to
number three the more I'm getting into
this and the more my phone is lighting
up the teams that are dying for a
quarterback after Joe burrow it might be
very limited I don't know if there's a
great demand for that third pick to get
that quarterback whether it be two or
Harbert and there's going to be a bunch
of liars poker going on because the way
I see it right now especially with
Jameis and Cam and Andy Dalton still
sitting out there there isn't a line of
teams looking to move up in the draft to
go get a quarterback after one and two
or off the board
yeah and I could see where Dalton and
Cam and Jameis once the draft is over
might have a better sense of where they
could end up but I I'm with you on this
I don't know if somebody's going up to
get to a or Justin Herbert it feels like
the Chargers are willing to just wait
and see who falls into their lap I think
it comes down to the Dolphins and does
this make them nervous of we got to go
up to get him but I also think it feels
like it's more of the fear of taking him
or the fear of not taking him what do
you think is a stronger opinion on -
it's such a great point because you
don't want to be we all watch the last
dance
you don't want to be the GM of the
Blazer saying well we passed on number
two with Michael Jordan because he
already had Clyde Drexler if you're the
Dolphins you don't want to say well we
passed on to a because who do that
chance for our doctors to see him and
then he goes on it has his great NFL
career the issue though is and it's not
just as one injury he plays in a style
of football that makes him very
susceptible to injuries he plays
fearless and you love that and he plays
a such great passion but he is not a guy
who was sitting in the pocket throwing
the ball right away on third down to
kind of get pick out the punt team no
he's always looking to extend the tray
he's always looking to make plays the
same reasons people around the league
and there are a few who love to and
they've got those few that I know
actually have quarterbacks they're happy
with it's the same reason the other
teams might be hesitating taking him
because this isn't some freak injury
it's not Sam Bradford who it's a pocket
quarterback and got a couple hits
there's a quarterback who runs a lot and
the quarterback who looked to get the
extra yard and it's hard to tell a guy
going into his NFL career okay that's
not going to work in the pros you're
gonna have to tone that down when that's
exactly what was successful for him at
the college game why do we change the
rules when it comes to a quarterback
that if any other player had the injury
history that too has and let's say he's
a marquee player if there was a wide
receiver who had anywhere near these
injuries or a running back or if chase
young had any of these injury we would
run from them but it feels like they're
team or teams that go you know what
we're gonna roll the dice hey those
quarterbacks like this don't come along
very often and you talk yourself in and
you talk to yourself out of these
situations but with the quarterback
that's why these GM's always amaze me
because sometimes they get stupid when
it comes to draft day and what they do
and they get nervous and we got to get
our quarterback here and I just I'm
surprised though with two of what the
injury history is and people can go yeah
but or he's never been healthier
although you know he's you know our
medical staff checked him and all these
things where you go buddy he still had
some pretty important injuries here
yeah but he also had some pretty
important wins this is one I know I know
those tricks with your mind because you
know the Wonderlic scores came out and
looked like to it in through so hot on
that be like well many no saben who has
had every college guy go through season
raves about him and it's not like he'd
ever he has to do it
Sabin raves about him I could tell you
privately he has called multiple coaches
and it made the case as to why two or
such a great young man in such a leader
so this is one of those deals where
you're right the correct position is
different look Makai Becton there was an
anonymous Scout who came out and said
Makai Becton has a hobby and his hobby
is cooking and because he's 360 times
and and I'm telling you teams are
calling me and like do you think Beckman
is gonna explode the five hundred pounds
like you're looking for things with
other positions get with quarterback
there are glaring glaring red flags here
with an injury and yet all it takes is
one team to say yeah but we look damn we
were we were both cover in the draft
when Josh McDaniels took Tim Tebow and I
don't think anyone else was taken in the
first round Johnny Manziel went in the
first round Blake bortles went third
overall because the Jaguars convinced
themselves that yeah but I don't know
this is this is what happened you don't
want to have a bad red flag on your
resume but she also would love to say
hey I'm Brett beech I'm the one who
traded up and got Patrick mahomes
despite a losing record at last year in
college give me the trade that you think
will happen the trade that I think will
happen I think the Niners are going to
move back from 31 for sure because they
don't have a second or third round pick
the question is what are the Niners do
at 13 this is where you get John Lynch
becoming a bit of a maverick out here
because he traded DeForest Buckner is an
incredible player for that 13th overall
pick and there might be a lot of
talented players there the bear Baron
with drafting so I would look at the
Niners as one team that could be trading
I'll also I would also look long and
hard at the Giants at score because I
know the Giants have needs on defense
but I think they're going offensive
tackle and from all the teams I'm
talking with there is such a split
decision on how these teams like the
tackles there's four guys and you guys
know them it's worse it's wills it's
Becton announced this guy Andrew Thomas
out of Georgia is getting a lot
female 8 if the Giants don't have a
clear number-one guy they could probably
trade back a few pics and still get one
of those four patriots said at
quarterback I don't think so
I think they're going to take somebody
here I don't know if they trade up to
get one of these major guys if they fit
pretty at 23 and take this Jordan Jordan
love is he sitting there or if it their
third-round pick they package a few
others moved to the second round and I
look at names like like this kid Jacob
Eason out of Washington who's got a big
arm and in play at Georgia then he
played at Washington and maybe he can be
the guy or the total opposite Jake from
who replaced Eason at Georgia who is
really an intellectual and one of these
just tremendous quarterbacks what they
say above the above the neck he's just
one of these smart bright guys that can
lead you if you need them to I think the
Patriots are going to take a quarterback
at some point in this draft and then
they'll have a challenge between Stidham
who they like I can tell you they like
them and then whoever they drachten the
draft would be a good open competition
with Brian Hoyer at the backup
Peter Schrager co-host of NFL Network's
good morning football you can also
listen to him with Jay Glazer and Joel
Klat the entire first round on Thursday
on Fox Sports Radio breaking down each
pick by each team in that first round
you start to look at some of these
situations here with the running back
and we've seen teams that over value
these running backs you know you look at
the Giants and what they did you look at
Carolina and what they did Jacksonville
and what they've done are we gonna have
running backs taken in the top 10
anytime soon or top 15 because I can get
these running backs I get Swift or
Dobyns at some point in the second round
or maybe even though you know at the end
of the first round but I wonder the
value of the running back now in future
drafts it it goes back and forth because
saycome Barkley everyone loved they're
like oh yeah he was worthy the second
overall pick the Giants have won five
games last year and I think four games
near before that so was it the second
overall pick no matter how good he is or
is it just a product of the Giants were
bad everywhere else Christian McCaffrey
was incredible last year the Panthers
didn't split the fall off so are you
looking for stats oh you're looking for
that
are you looking for a guy who's going to
make an immediate impact on a team that
you maybe it's it's not necessarily a
need but you think the best player on
the not a running blog I I'm fascinated
with the Andre Smith I'm fascinated with
Clyde Edward a layer who's an LSU
running back he touched on Saturdays who
was fantastic both these guys if there
was 1998 would be top 10 picks you know
but it's not it's not 1998 it's not 2008
it's now 2020 and I could see no running
backs in the first round for exactly
your point you know for net CJ spiller
there's so many of these guys they get
taken up in picks yeah and they don't
necessarily pan out and I don't think I
don't think fur Nets had a bad NFL
career Burnett quote 75 passes last year
nothing against for net it's just you
add a running back are you making your
team better or are you just getting
another fantasy guy that's how these
that's how these GM's are looking at it
right now because if I can get a left
tackle that's going to protect my
quarterback much rather have my
quarterback upright for 16 weeks then a
running back who you know we went for
and 12 but a team that had four running
backs the 49ers went to the Super Bowl
good stuff is always Peter I hope you're
well and have fun with Jay and joke lat
starting Thursday night first round of
the draft on Fox Sports Radio and do you
did you hear about the potential lawsuit
with Tom Brady and the Tampa Bay
t-shirts are you up on this
I thought you cover the NFL we created
it and he just took it yeah he says that
he filed for the trademark here
we forgot to trademark it but you know
we spend so much time on coming up with
a brilliant t-shirt we just didn't think
about you know trademarking I just
didn't you know it slipped away I didn't
I didn't have the time sometimes you
think that you know it is people with
the goodness of their heart doesn't
happen like that maybe I can get maybe I
could get Kyle Brandis medium yeah this
meeting today he didn't have enough
search like that you need a population
in Tom Brady he needs the money from the
Tampa Bay trademark for sure that is
whether that's exactly what's going on
right here yeah but
we're going to uh we're gonna cease and
desist by the end of the month though
we've been asked to do that and and we
will do them I cannot wait till we're
all in person again it will happen Dan
and I will shake your hand or maybe not
but whatever we'll do we will be in
studio and things will be back to normal
thank you thank you Peter that's Peter
shraeger
co-host NFL Network's good morning
football or as he likes to say the heart
and soul of good morning football